I stand before you not as well Terry's
carpet
I have long believed that the most
elegant way to drive innovation and to
reduce carbon emissions is to put a
price on we need to price carbon a
revenue-neutral carbon tax a broad-based
carbon price we need to put a price tag
on carbon emissions be tax on carbon
carbon tux they revenue-neutral carbon
tax so what we want to do is have a fee
for carbon carbon dioxide production and
then we will return the feet of the
people in the form of sharply reduced
taxes on payrolls to give everyone an
incentive to to implement the energy
efficiency proposals is it taking so
much time we don't deal well with
gradual long-term problems or it'll have
to think it's urgent the difficulty of
this process is they're trying to get a
hundred percent of countries to agree if
it's the right thing for the future a
cutter should just do it and don't worry
about what other countries are doing
just do the right thing if you put a
price on it then the entire market would
respond it can largely be built on the
existing tax infrastructure we tax
alcohol and cigarettes much more than we
tax fruits and vegetables it's just sort
of the sensible thing to do and I'm
standing here as an airline owner saying
a carbon tax should be levied on
airlines this is not a partisan debate
it is a human one conservatives
originally figured out this was a
smarter way to deal with pollution
carbon pricing is critical for reducing
emissions preserving our environment and
protecting the most vulnerable this will
be by far the most effective thing for
accelerating that transition to a good
future the time to answer humankind's
greatest challenge is now
you